My oncologist is not suggesting chemo at this time but he wants me, wants to put me on the
following to stop the growth of breast cancer. His colleague is the CDK46 inhibitor pill
if blocks the growth of signal cells in the cancer cells and stops and tells them to stop
going into growth cycle. So this is a medication. Phospholidex is, this is what we just talked about,
it's a monthly injectable that blocks the estrogen receptor. So we just talked about the last
question. My cancer cells have a high expression of estrogen receptor. The struggle block that by
kicking estrogen off the receptor and we just talked about the only other thing that does that is
the Highland 951 that are embedded so in. Any comments on this approach? Well, I can't legally tell
you to take or not to take a medication even in a group Zoom call like this so I can't really tell
you what to do with that. I'm not familiar with this drug here really at all so I would have to
look up some studies just like you would on that drug right there. This drug obviously
has all the negative side effects of blocky estrogens that no women like to experience
and many women will start out something like that and go I want to get off of it just like this
person or this question. I want to stop taking it usually they're having side effects of you know
decreasing estrogen and and all the symptoms that go along with that they want to do a natural
approach to do that instead of using a medication. Those are really the biggest comments you see
any issue with continuing to take Highland at estro clear. You can even if you decide to go on
in Pazlodex you can still take these nutrients so Highland 951 is a complete food-based product so
there's no interactions with Highland whatsoever. Estro clear is a lignit. There's no interactions
with that whatsoever either so I also plan to continue detoxing and taking antioxidants to
see any issues with this. The only thing that I don't know what that kiss quality is if it's an
oxidizing agent or not. If it is an oxidizing agent then you you just have to consider that if you're
taking high dose antioxidants you could be negating the effect of an oxidizing agent if this is
what that if that is what that is. I don't I don't think so but you'd have to google that if I don't.